Speaker 1: Let's go to Carol Lin from
Utah. Carol Lin from Utah. Welcome to
the David Pakman show. What's on your
mind today? What can I do for you?
Carolyn from Utah, you've been invited to join.
Speaker 3: Welcome me.
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Okay, great. I've been a long
time listener. And now this is the question.
Okay. I'm from Utah. Like I like you said.
Yeah. We have a Republican governor, Cox, who is
more of a moderate, mainstream Republican. He's
not too far to the left or too far to the right.
But he had nominated a Democratic person to go to
our Environmental Council or whatever. And the
Republican, the people who would approve this
nomination and of course, put it down and they
said, no, you can't be on the committee. Now,
my question has to do with the fact that they're
looking for so long. A lot more information role
in regards to climate change and things like
that, and in particular the way the Democrats
act. So now some of these mainstream Republicans
are trying to, of course, make a turn around
and when they realize they went too far. Is there
any way that you think that they can pull back
the Republican Party? Sort of. I don't
know. I worried about the Civil War thing,
but this sort of civil war, is there any way
that we can pull back the people that are.
So far, they can't understand reason and logic.
Speaker 1: So, Carolyn, I apologize. A lot of the
first stuff you said I did that, Carolyn, and a
lot of the first stuff you said I didn't really
understand. And you also had a couple of audio
glitches in there. But but what I think you're
asking me is, is there any way to pull extremist
Republicans who are in fantasyland kind of back to
reality? Is that generally your question?
Speaker 3: Yeah, but in particular,
if there's any way. Well, for the
mainstream Republicans to do it,
I don't think we have any chance.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. I think the best shot that
mainstream Republicans, to the extent that they
still exist, have to pull the extremists back to
reality is by proving to them, really showing them
that if you guys are the direction the party goes,
we lose. I think that that's the only way. And
even then, I think that if the MAGA extremist wing
just started losing badly. I don't even know that
you would convert a lot of those people. I think
a lot of those people would give up and leave
politics. So it's not it might not even really be
a conversion. But I do think that it's possible
that with all of these people, but with some,
if Republicans start taking more and more and
more losses as they already have, but even more,
and then the mainstream Republicans say it's
because of you, we need to come back to something
more approximating like Mitt Romney or John
McCain. I think that that's their best shot.
And even that may not work. I don't know.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that would be great. So
I know there's been a lot of articles lately about
cyber war and everything. What do you think our
chances are of ending up in something like that.
Speaker 1: As of right now? So I never like to
make these long term predictions. The U.S. will
never have a civil war. We just don't know. The
way I would assess it, as I see the chance of a
civil war over the next five years as extremely
close to zero, not zero, but extremely close to
zero over the next five years. That's kind of
where I'm comfortable going right now.
Speaker 3: Okay. All right. Well,
thank you so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Pleasure. Carolyn from
Utah. Great to hear from you.